nos dan este triángulo abc y nos piden
encontrar este coseno ahora el triángulo
abc parece ser rectángulo y de hecho lo
es
lo podemos verificar porque 8 al
cuadrado más 15 al cuadrado sería 64 más
225 que es 289 que precisamente es 17 al
cuadrado así que esto de aquí es un
ángulo recto esto es un triángulo
rectángulo pero el problema lo que nos
pide es evaluar el coseno del ángulo abc
el ángulo abc es el ángulo que está aquí
este de aquí es el ángulo abc más 60
grados así que de entrada no tengo un
modo quizás directo de evaluar esto pero
nosotros sabemos de nuestros vídeos de
trigonometría algunas identidades
trigonométricas por ejemplo nosotros
sabemos que él coseno
además ve
es igual a el coseno de a por el cose no
debe menos el seno de a
- el seno de a por el seno de b así que
vamos a sustituir a por el ángulo abc y
b por 60 grados así que obtendría que el
coseno de el ángulo abc más 60 grados va
a ser igual a quien pues va a ser igual
a
el coseno
del ángulo abc
por el coseno de 60 grados por el coseno
de 60 grados lucas si no tengo espacio
aquí menos
- el seno del ángulo abc
el coseno por el pse no perdón por el
seno de 60 grados y vamos a evaluar cada
una de estas cosas directamente porque
no comenzamos con el coseno del ángulo
abc el coseno del ángulo abc el seno del
ángulo abc pues para ver cuánto vale voy
a remitirme a lo que ya sabíamos que era
el sol acá toda toca toda era nuestra
abreviación para seno es igual a opuesto
entre hipotenusa coseno es igual a
adyacente entre hipotenusa y tangente es
igual a opuesto entre adyacente así que
bien cuánto vale el coseno del ángulo a
veces el coseno de este ángulo de aquí
pues el cateto adyacente sería este vale
15 y la hipotenusa vale 17 así que sería
15 entre 17 ahora que hay del coseno de
60 grados cuánto vale el coseno de 60
grados pues para ello me remito a
nuestros triángulos 60 30 90 que se ven
algo así este ángulo x 90
sería 30 30 grados y esto sería 60
grados y entonces esta hipotenusa vale 1
este lado opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados
vale un medio y este lado opuesto el
ángulo de 60 grados vale raíz de 3 entre
2 pueden pensar en esto como un
triángulo equilátero partido por la
mitad pero bueno entonces el coseno de
60 grados
el coseno de 60 grados sería el cateto
adyacente entre la hipotenusa que sería
lo mismo que un medio entre 1 que es
sencillamente un medio bien ahora que
hay del seno
de el ángulo a b c
pues el seno de este ángulo sería el por
nuestra fórmula de soca tohá sería seno
es igual a opuesto entre hipotenusa el
cateto opuesto a este ángulo sería el
cateto de valor 8 y la hipotenusa
nuevamente vale 17 así que este seno
vale 8 entre 17 y que hay del seno de 60
grados el seno de 60 grados pues de
nuevo me fijo en mi triángulo es cateto
opuesto entre hipotenusa así que vale
raíz de 3 entre 2
entre 1 o lo que es lo mismo simplemente
raíz de 3 entre 2 así que bien ya tengo
todos los ingredientes para sustituir
acá
de modo que
pero escribo con rojo el coche no del
ángulo abc
+ 60 grados es igual a el coseno del
ángulo abc que es 15 entre 17 15 entre
17 por el cocina 60 grados que lo
tenemos aquí es un medio por un medio
menos el seno del ángulo abc que es 8
entre 17 así que menos 8 / 17
por el seno de 60 grados que es raíz de
3 / 2
así que vamos a simplificar un poco esta
cuenta cuánto sería 15 entre 17 sería 15
entre 34 menos 8 por raíz de 3 entre 17
entre 2 sería lo mismo que cuatro por
raíz de 3 entre 17 y realmente no lo
podemos simplificar más porque como
tenemos esa raíz en este numerador
siempre vamos a obtener un factor
irracional así que esto ya está
suficiente simplificado para el problema